hola soy mister anderson y bienvenido el
vídeo de termorregulación en donde
hablaremos de como algunos organismos
auto regulan su temperatura interna o no
así que básicamente aquí tenemos la
imagen térmica de un brazo humano que
está siendo rodeado por una serpiente y
bueno por acá tenemos a la temperatura y
nuestra temperatura corporal está a
aproximadamente 37 grados celsius
mientras que cuál es la temperatura de
la serpiente bueno la temperatura de la
serpiente es igual a la temperatura del
ambiente y eso es porque las serpientes
son de sangre fría o ectotermos pero
antes de que hablemos de eso hablaremos
acerca del calor así que imagina que
tenemos una vela por aquí y por acá
tenemos tomando una de las formas en la
que puedes transferir calor de la vela
hacia tu mano sería poner tu dedo en la
flama pero ten cuidado porque si haces
eso las moléculas de la flama van a
interactuar con las moléculas de tu dedo
ya eso se le conoce como conducción
de hecho no hagas eso porque te quemarás
si lo haces así que es mejor si no lo
haces de esta manera ahora bien también
hay otras formas de transferir calor una
de ellas es pensar en lo siguiente si
pones el dedo aquí y observa no estás
poniendo el dedo directamente en la
flama pero aún así vas a sentir un poco
de calor ahora también puedes poner el
dedo arriba de la pluma de esta manera
en este caso va a ser más doloroso para
ti que el dolor que se siente a un lado
porque te quemara más y la razón del por
qué pasa esto es justo la segunda forma
de transferir calor y esta es la
convección y que es la convección bueno
es la forma de transferir calor mediante
el movimiento de un fluido y en este
caso el fluido que se está moviendo es
el aire el calor en el aire se eleva y
esto hace que sientas más calor cuando
tienes el dedo arriba de la flama así
que bueno hasta aquí ya tenemos dos
formas para transferir el calor la
siguiente forma de transferencia del
calor es por ejemplo cuando pones tu
dedo aquí y entre tu dedo y la flama hay
vacío
si tienes ese caso vas a sentir un poco
de calor por aquí tal vez no sea mucho
pero vas a sentir un poco del calor de
la vela y esto es por la radiación la
radiación es importante porque si este
fuera el sol y este fueras tú en la
tierra entonces la luz se movería en el
vacío que existe en el espacio y
esencialmente llega a ti así que estas
son las formas en las que se puede
obtener calor puedes obtener calor por
la radiación del sol por el movimiento
del aire o tal vez tocando algo caliente
ahora también hay otra forma de obtener
calor la cual sirve para los seres vivos
y es de hecho la respiración es decir
debido al metabolismo podemos generar
calor entonces la vida tiene dos
diferentes estrategias para poder
interactuar con el calor la primera
estrategia se le conoce como héctor o
término y etimológicamente significa
calor del exterior estas tortugas aquí
son ectotermos eso significa que ellas
obtienen su temperatura de sueño
así que ellas van a tener la misma
temperatura que la temperatura del
cuarto y cuál es la ventaja de eso bueno
la ventaja de eso es que no tienen que
gastar energía en crear calor adentro de
ellas por lo tanto no tienes que
alimentar a una tortuga tantas veces por
ejemplo las serpientes comen una vez al
mes o algunas tal vez una vez al año eso
si comen algo muy pero muy grande porque
ellas no requieren una gran cantidad de
energía ahora la desventaja de esto es
que si tienes un clima muy frío entonces
todo el metabolismo todas las enzimas
dentro de tu cuerpo van a trabajar más
lento también es por eso que muchas
veces los externos se calientan por las
mañanas escalando una roca o tomando el
sol ahora la otra forma es ser
endotermos y si eres endotermos como
estar diría de aquí mi estadía terrestre
entonces no tienes que preocuparte por
eso y la razón de esto es porque tú vas
a generar calor dentro de ti
gracias a tu metabolismo entonces cuál
es la temperatura de estar diría bueno
probablemente sea cercana a la nuestra y
si baja de temperatura
bueno seguirá siendo cercana a la
nuestra y si la temperatura aumenta
estad y ya me seguirá teniendo una
temperatura cercana a la nuestra
así que una ventaja de ser endotermos es
que tu temperatura interna siempre va a
ser la misma ahora bien cuál es la
desventaja bueno la desventaja va a ser
que constantemente vas a necesitar comer
una y otra y otra y otra vez muy bien
entonces como mantenemos nuestra
temperatura del 2 endotermos bueno
esencialmente lo que vamos a hacer es
usar un asa de retroalimentación
negativa eso quiere decir que usamos
algo que se conoce como el pot álamo el
cual se encuentra en la base de tu
cerebro y este hipotálamo constantemente
está averiguando cuál es la temperatura
del cuerpo así que si la temperatura se
eleva mucho arriba de la temperatura
corporal
básicamente el hipo está
amo lo que hace es mandar la señal de
reaccionar a esta temperatura y podemos
reaccionar de muchas formas una de ellas
se sudando otra forma de reaccionar a
eso es empezar una vasodilatación es
decir se dilatan los capilares y con eso
vamos a obtener más sangre cerca de la
superficie de nuestro cuerpo y así vamos
a perder más calor esto hará que baje
nuestra temperatura y ahora si la
temperatura baja demasiado qué pasará
bueno si la temperatura baja demasiado
vamos a empezar a tener escalofríos
tenemos lo que se conoce como piel de
gallina con lo que vamos a mantener a la
piel cerca de nosotros y además vamos a
tener una vasoconstricción es decir
vamos a mantener esa temperatura cerca
de nuestro cuerpo y eso básicamente va a
aumentar nuestra temperatura
regresándola al punto adecuado bien
constantemente estamos haciendo esto y
la ventaja de ello es que mantenemos la
temperatura de nuestro cuerpo cerca al
punto de objetivo y
este es un punto de control objetivo
perfecto para que todas las enzimas que
tenemos dentro de nuestro cuerpo
funcionen de manera óptima bien así que
esto fue el vídeo de termorregulación
espero lo hayas encontrado útil